hello everybody so I will talk a little
bit about what data table actually is
and why we started as a project and what
is its aims and go so the project
started over two over two years ago and
at that point the main domain tool on on
the landscape for data manipulation was
pendous it still remains the main tool
but like then the other projects such as
dusk and arrow were in very very initial
stage and were basically not usable so
and we really needed something to work
with big data because our we had we had
the need for big data manipulation and
we need we needed have a very high
performance multi-threaded algorithm
full utilization of CPU and so on so we
started this project as as an
alternative to panda so we think
ourselves as a pandas competitor and
that part remained many things changed
about the table over the years but that
part remained true until today
so we aim at being doing the same same
thing as pandas only it's a little bit
better way but it's also important to
understand what at the table is not so I
just said that we aim to be better than
data table as it found us but we are not
actually better than pandas we
understand that and we probably will
never be better than pandas in a sense
that it's important we believe that the
core of our understanding is that we
have to have a competition to build good
products because if there is only a
single product in any kind of landscape
then it will never be good or maybe
it'll be good but you will never know
that it is good because you can you have
nothing to compare against so as long as
you have several competitor competitive
competitor for the product you know that
one of them is better in one place other
is another in another place so we are
grateful to although all those other
competitive competitors that we
facing and we are constantly strive to
surpass them and they constantly strive
to surpass us and this is why we believe
that it is through this process of
competition that we will actually
achieve great product not by being just
good by ourselves so we talked about I
already mentioned that the main
challenges for data table was that we
wanted to support huge amounts of data
so currently we can process up to 100
gigabytes of data on on a powerful
machine on a single node machine and we
aim to raise at Leman probably at least
10 times in the coming year so we wanted
to to have uniform uniform support for
missing values
so in pandas there is some support in
missing values but not for all column
times column types in arrow now they
have support missing arrows values in
all types so missing features are
extremely important in data science this
is why it was on the top of our list and
we wanted we wanted it to be memory
frugal because we notice that sometimes
it's not everything not everything is
about speed sometimes when you have
really big data it's important that the
data does not overshot your memory
because no matter how how how big your
server is even if it has a terabyte of
RAM for example you still probably will
end up having more data than you RAM so
it's important to be as frugal as and as
thrifty with your memory usage as
possible and this is this one of our
goals in designing the deity and we'll
talk about a little bit about syntax
because if for those of you who know our
data table can in recent who knows our
data table or a few people so those who
familiar is our the table work is seen
it note that it has like very
interesting syntax unlike everything
else so we borrowed that syntax and it's
a different approach to how how you do
things in pandas and
you will see whether whether you like it
or not some people like it some people
don't but it's a distinctive approach
and we believe that it needs some more
expressive power so let's start this a
high this high-level overview of the
library so we have a main class which is
a frame and it is the same as equivalent
of pandas dataframe and notably we don't
have a serious object so in pandas you
have both frames in series which is a
columns in the frame
we don't have columns at least
externally everything is is a frame so
it makes API a little bit simpler to
work with you don't need you don't need
to to swap between different object
types so then we also have these little
helper functions by joint sort and
update they are used to perform basic
operators which are suggested by their
names then there is a this.f symbol
which states for frame proxy and we'll
talk about it a little bit more it's a
little bit mysterious looking right now
so then there is a namespace in the main
namespace we also have a lot of other
functions such as some min Max and
notably most of the functions are in the
main namespace not on the not on the
main class because well because the
inspiration for API comes a little bit
from our and this is how things are done
in our so we also have mass functions in
the mass names namespace and also we
even have models because we do a lot of
machine learning algorithms so some of
the machine learning algorithms end up
and that up bundle is a data table
library so let's start is a frame class
so first thing that is mentioned here is
a class is 100% implemented in C so this
is because we really believe that's the
core of the of the library the main the
main class must be as fast as possible
so there is not a single person line of
code in
and it provides basic properties same
same as you would expect from from any
other data frame number of rows number
of calls columns names types but in
inside a frame is just a simple
collection of columns was their names
and this collection is both an array and
the dictionary so you can think of it as
something that is both the dictionary
and array of columns and I'm talking a
little bit about the insights because I
think it is important when you use a
library to understand a little bit how
how it is working inside because then
you can reason better about which
operations how much each operation costs
how much does it cost
to select a column how much does it cost
to subset at how much does it cost to
make a sort and so on and if you have
understanding of how the library does
things internally you can reason about
that otherwise you will end up producing
inefficient code so each column is easy
easy c c++ object and each column is a
shared pointer the shared pointer means
that whenever with copy columns we don't
actually call copy them we just copy the
pointer and it means that it's a free
operation basically so selecting columns
selecting subsets of columns from a
frame is a no cost operation so one
important difference is also we select
columns by just sharing pointers there
is never situation we're changing one
one column affects everything else it
was copied from that because we use we
use a copy-on-write semantics copyright
semantics basically is whenever we try
to modify the date in a column it
automatically creates a copy of itself
modifies a copy and then everybody else
remains with the old with all data that
way you never end up in a situation
where you select something you saved it
in variable and then from somewhere else
it was modified and then somehow the
data we can
repped corrupted and so on and in order
to battle that usually you would see in
the cold people do dip copies all the
time you copy the puppy the puppy deep
copy so in data table we don't ever do
the copies like we have that operation
but it's never it's never useful you can
also just use use a regular coffee
so also each column has his knowledge of
its basic stats such as min max some
average and so on and these stats are
memorized which means that once you
compute them they are available for
later use and you don't need to
recompute them so many algorithms are
actually can use the knowledge of the
basic stats of the call and optimize
some some of the operations based on
based on those stats so if for example
if you know that the range is small the
minimum between maximum you can use one
order it if you know that the reason
there are no na is in the column you can
use another algorithm if you know that
the string column contains only Scie
data you can use a simpler algorithm and
so on so all of these simple stats are
used in to select better performing
algorithm at runtime and one of them one
of the more important feature that was
introduced in the latest version is that
the columns can also be virtual and
virtual means that they are computed on
the fly so we believe that it's an
important part of our architecture
because it allows us not to store as
much data in memory if you know that
because many of the things that we that
we do with columns is do some kind of
transformations and then when you do
transform you end up storing the new
data in memory and then quickly you eat
up all those available in their memory
and this is not something that you want
to do we would rather prefer to store
the sequence of transformations that you
apply to the column and then materialize
only the end result so that way the
memories at little that that was used to
arrive at that final result result was
now I was never consumed
which means that which gets to that
memory frugal part of our objectives as
we talked about but in all in all
respects virtual columns are completely
transparent to the user so you don't
actually you usually don't know whether
a column is virtual not it just works it
works perfectly so here are some of the
examples how it can be used let's say we
are loading the data from another from a
third-party library let's say from numpy
so instead of copying the data from a
third source from that other source we
create a virtual column that knows how
to refer to that data and this is by the
way our approach to to arrow challenge
and the challenge of the arrow project
was that there was too much copying the
being done between different projects if
you want to send data into other library
you need to copy it you need to copy it
from here to from there instead of and
they say we need to have a common format
so everybody would use and achieve that
code to achieve that common format is
hard our answer to the same challenge is
that we are going to just ingest the
data without copying at all through the
virtual columns so we know how to read
the data from different sources on the
fly and we don't need to copy that so
another example is if you want to select
a subset of columns it's a very common
task for example we have a dataset and
100 million rows and you need to to do
to split it in a tray in a test so it
may be a test dataset is on ten million
rows so you would you would create a set
of indices which rows you want to select
and then you we would create just a
virtual column that says retrieve me
data from those indices we will not
actually put that select the data from
those columns and copy it into a new
frame you will just say that we know how
to retrieve that the data and this is
done virtually on the fly
similarly if you when we are doing we
join in join is an operation where we
where we compute how the rows of one
frame correspond to the rows of another
frame and then there is a row index and
no data is actually being copied into a
final result we just know how to how to
compute the data in the end and present
to the user in grouping is a similar
operation where we also compute their
index of how which row which of the
relation corresponds to which group and
this allows us to ungroup on-the-fly and
apply each ovary and apply each
operation to son grouped data and of
course basic arithmetic operations such
as functions costs and so on so on they
are perfectly natural
candidates for virtual Commerce and one
other thing that we are planning to
implement in them in the coming versions
is to also support compress data and
encrypted data and finally the sparse
data as well everything actually can be
implemented using the same paradigm so
now a little bit about the syntax so
this the name of the slide is DT IJ by
so if if you have seen the our data
table you know what it is if you did not
then this is the mainframe method so
frame is in our main class and this is
its main method so it may seem weird
like why do we have a main method why
don't we have like a hundred different
methods and this is a this is where
where's the the data table main idea is
that we want to have a single method
that does all the operations and this is
how how we do it so we say that and this
single method doesn't even have a name
it's just a square brackets so we are
saying that it has this part which I
which is selection of rows and J
selection for columns and then there are
also additional verbs such as by which
tell us how to group how to group
operations and join what to join twist
so on so using that that a single
expression we can actually implement
pretty much all the operations that data
operations that we need and there is a
nice parallel with sequel because in
sequel they also have a very limited
number of main main expressions which is
select select something like J which is
in our case columns so then from has a
data from a table where I is a condition
of where to select so these are this is
a row selector and then they also have
the modifiers such as group join in
order so and similarly they have in
sickle also the main they delete and
update verbs and in in pison delete is
just a del operator and update is just
an assignment so using a single square
bracket notation we can achieve a lot of
results until you will see examples of
that and during the hands-on session so
what can we what do we put in this IG by
right now just abstract things and we
want to put there everything that we
want that we can think of so basically
as long as you can assign some meaning
meaning to that anything and it's
unambiguous then we want to support it
so things like integer indices strings
which would mean column names slices
column slides a string slices ranges
frames numpy raised by some types data
table types lists dictionaries
everything even and finally the
expression so expressions is the topic
of the next slide but basically we're
saying that if you can put something
there and you can say I think this
should mean this and we don't support it
then we consider it to bark right we we
think that this the syntax should be
supporting any possible kind of
expression so let's talk about the
expressions expressions is where is when
you do calculations over the call
so first at the example of how you do
things in pandas in pandas you would say
you have a frame you select a column
frame a and then there is you select not
a column frame B and you add them so
this is how you write an expression in
pandas in data table you use a square
notation so there is a frame and there
is a square bracket apply it and
remember that square bracket in sides
they have I which is rows and J which is
a column so in this case we don't care
about anything any filtering so the eye
is just a colon which means that all the
rows and then the Jade is what you do
with columns and in this case it's after
a plus F dot B so f dot a is a sure is a
shortcut for column a of this frame so f
you can think of it as is this ourself
and it's a frame proxy meaning that it
it automatically binds to whatever
expression has been calculated in so
it's a little bit magical but generally
you can think of it as just a shortcut
of how you refer to columns instead of
having to repeat the name of the frame
every single time you just have a single
letter F and and if you don't like the F
because some people don't like that you
can just export the names of you can say
you can assign those variables to the
two variables and then just use them as
it is in a square of recommendation so
but F is a powerful syntax so it can be
used not just as a dot notation so dot
notation is just a simple kind so if you
have a more complex complicated column
name you can put it in square brackets
for example if it's not an ID or if it
if you have an variable you can put it
in the square brackets if you have an
index you can put there you can select a
slice of columns you can select the
string slice of columns you can select
all columns you can even select almost
by type and you can use it those F
expressions inside any kind of IJ by and
so on
and then once you select them you can
apply functions to source F so for
example yeah most of our functions they
automatically they automatically map
through all the columns so for example
the first expression here means it says
mean of F float so f float selects all
the floor type columns then mean of that
means that the mean functions is applied
to every of every one of those columns
so the result is that we'll have a frame
that contains the means of every single
column so the second expression says
take the first three column and the last
three columns and add them together so
they will be added component wise the
plastics expression says select all the
integer columns and then assign the type
and sending times means a type cost so
basically this just converts a type of
all integer called columns into fluid
calls we also have row wise functions
that takes a selection of columns such
as let's say all columns or all cons are
the other than the last and combines
them into a single column so row mean
means that take all the columns and find
average of all those columns and in the
last example we take the we take all the
columns we apply is a named function
which against maps across all the
columns and then we find V applies that
any row any which means find me there
bro those rows were any of the value in
any column isn't a name and then they
leave those row so basically it deletes
every row where there are any names so
in short we believe that data table is a
package that is alternative to pandas
it's doesn't have the full range of
functionality the same as palaces but it
has its uses in particularly it's a it's
very useful when you face a lot of the
very big data payloads such as hundreds
or tens of hundreds of gigabyte of data
and when you need a lot of
interoperability with other framework so
in data table we have a lot of data
conversions from data table dependence
or to numpy and back and back and all of
that is trying to thank you Pasha so I
know it's a lot of technical material
for nine o'clock in the morning on a
Tuesday so but we're very grateful that
you're here and that we have a chance to
share more about this awesome library so
the next portion of this of the session
we're gonna do a bit more of the
hands-on okay so now we're going to come
back to aquarium so I know there's a few
of you who just can't who came in so if
you haven't done so please go to
aquarium that h2o that AI we need to
make sure that everyone has that
environment one of the requirements was
- so one of the requirements was to have
data table install and also to have a
Jupiter lab but we're actually going to
provide that for you because I know that
every world right now currently one of
the limitations with data table is that
it does it doesn't work on Windows
unless you have a docker container so
we're going to actually provide an
environment for you and that will be an
aquarium that h2o dye you should see h2o
that AI and then you have browse labs if
you click on that then you should be
able to see an array of labs in here
we're going to pick lab 5 so it's titled
lab ideas number five and it's the David
Whiting's H 2 O 3 and sparkling water so
we're not gonna do anything with H 2 O 3
and sparkling water but we will be using
the lab a Jupiter lab notebook in here
so again you should be at aquarium that
h2o dot AI you need to create an account
once you create an account you're going
there's going to be a
passwords sent to your email right away
and then you can just log back in and go
to browse labs the dashboard if you have
something running then you should the
dashboard will look something like this
but we're not there yet so let's go to
browse labs and select lab 5 lab ID 5
make sure you select that one because if
you click on the other labs which you
are welcome to do so
at some other time it does take a while
those labs have different notebooks and
they require they they start like they
take about five minutes to start we're
not there yet we already have some pre
run and pre run environment for you so
if you click on lab 5 you'll see
something like this ok so now we're
going to select the Jupiter URL so right
at the bottom of the lab so again we're
in lap number 5 so I went to browse labs
selected lab ID number 5 clicked on View
detail and then right at the bottom
there's a section called Jupiter URL
we're going to click on that so click on
it and then the following page should
come up
oh the password I know you should look
start in the lab I'm sorry I guess mine
already started so click a click start
and then you should get a link right
away it shouldn't take long to - so if
you're in the wrong lab then you do
click start and it's just gonna take a
long time because it hasn't pre-loaded
but you if you click start you should
get ru of the page here that I just had
yeah for the Jupiter lab ok the password
is h2o so thank you for bearing with us
we just want to make sure everyone has
the same environment and that you know
how to install anything on your machine
ok so we're there h2o
ok so if you're there then we're back to
Jupiter lab
okay now we're gonna go to github to get
the notebook okay so the next one we're
gonna go to this is the URL HTTP
[Music]
can you guys see that it's HTTP colon
slash slash github.com h2o tutorials can
you see that the URL there okay so if
you go there or is everyone happy did
everyone go to that URL you should get
that's gonna take you to the github repo
for our tutorials is everyone there not
yet okay please let me know when I can
move on so I do have other instructions
here if you want to follow but I'll wait
for everyone to mention the the next
steps okay so we went to HTTPS and we
went to the github our github repo for
our tutorials we have different branches
so this is a repo for h2o day.i we have
different products and therefore
different tutorials we are building our
repo so if you would like to explore
some other time we do have we try to we
want to make sure that we have the
latest and greatest of the product
specifically for driverless AI but for
this particular conference we did a data
table section so if you go to branch if
you're if you're not too familiar with
if you're familiar with github you can
go to the branches and select AC PI data
table / - tutorial that would be where
we have I have the folder that's called
python data table so let me go to the
repo bear with me we just trying to make
sure we get the environment we'll run to
the notebook quickly
okay so this is the github repo we're
gonna go to branch and we're gonna go to
the one that says AC / PI data table
tutorial and that should only be one
file we go to Python data table and
there should only be one notebook there
okay so if you click on click on it and
then we're gonna right click on raw and
save the link this so pretty much what
we're doing is we're just saving it to
our local machine so that we can upload
it into the notebook so I'm gonna go
back again
so we were in master when you
so we were in master and then we went to
the AC branch and then we went to pipe a
Python data table and then you click on
the notebook and then you save it but
you click right click on raw and you
save the link ass no it should be the
python the jupiter extension so if you
save it to your local machine then we
now we go back to the lab itself and
we're just gonna upload so is everyone
at the jupiter section where we're gonna
upload the all we're doing is we're
downloading the the notebook from github
and we're gonna upload it to jupiter so
is everyone does everyone have the file
in their local machine raise your hand
if you don't have the file so we have
one okay so guys my helping them out
okay so we're gonna have some people
walking around so we went to github for
the tutorial site and then we went ahead
and so we went to the AC branch and then
selected the python data table folder
and then selected the notebook inside of
it you click on it and if you click
right click on raw you should be able to
download it to your local machine okay
so are most of you guys most of you
there yeah any who else is still not
there raise your hand please make sure
you raise your hand we want to make sure
that you we we all come follow okay so
okay so now now that we're here in
jupiter we're gonna upload
and just select the the notebook that
you just downloaded so it should be
introduction to data analysis with
Python data table okay so select your
select the file click open and then it
should look something like this okay is
everyone there all right and just click
upload so you have to click upload once
and then upload again everyone is
everyone can you raise your hand if
you're not at this page yet still just
one person two three okay so the only
thing we have done is we created a query
environment we got a jupiter lab run
jupiter notebook running but we just
need to upload the file okay so we do
have a few people we're still not there
yet so we're i'm gonna try to give in
we've given and we have a short amount
of time
just gonna click upload okay so you
should see the notebook you can open it
as you can see it's not a complete
because i found that when you're running
you put our notebooks you can just click
run and it runs everything and you kind
of distract yourself and you're like
okay what did I just do
so we're going to this is going to be a
little bit of hands-on we're going to I
commented some stuff out I also deleted
some of the some of the commands so I
will be asking you to enter some of the
commands manually and then so that way
we can have a little bit you can have
some practice just entering some other
commands so you can see how easy it is
so okay so
everyone does everyone had the lab I
know I'm sorry this is taking a while
but you want to make sure everyone has
the lab so that everyone can can
experience how awesome data table is and
you'll be able to I'm going to be we're
going to be doing some comparisons
between we're gonna run data table and
then we're gonna run simultaneously the
next time and we're gonna run up pandas
so you can see the difference and we
want to make sure that you experience
the difference
so everyone and anyone else still raise
your hand if you're not here yet
everyone's here okay awesome
okay so the as I mentioned before the
data set that we will be using is the
Lending Club again how many of you are
not familiar with the Lending Club data
set okay
so for those of you who are not familiar
with the Lending Club data set so the
Lending Club is a non traditional
lending bank you could say that does
peer lending and so they provide
personal loans and they also provide
small loans to businesses so they
actually they have this you can actually
go and invest and when you want it if
you want to invest you can download the
data set you can see kind of like the
information about the the people the
type of people that apply for loans and
who gets a I guess who gets awarded
alone and who doesn't get awarded and
why they don't get awarded so it's a
really nice data set from what I found
if you're not familiar with Cagle you
can go to Cal gol you can see the the
data set but they this particular data
set that we're using this one has 2.6
million rows and a hundred and forty
five columns so we're talking a large
data set some of the other data sets
that I found for this particular the
Lending Club are as much smaller so the
one that if you're going to Cal go or if
you're going to the Lending Club you may
get a different data set so for this
particular data set which I last checked
yesterday is 2.6 million rows and 145
columns so this will get an out this
will give us a nice
chance to to experience data table okay
so first thing we're gonna do is we're
going to import a Python data table so I
comment it out for you but don't think
you could do if you're using Jupiter
notebook you could just do a pip install
data table and you can run that and it
will run the the latest version of data
table which in this case is zero point
ten zero which was just released this
morning so we got a fresh version of
data table and the way to check that is
if we go to the next cell we're gonna be
importing some of the libraries so as
this is a importing I want to mention
that for this particular data set there
it's a very large data set so we do get
a chance to it has information such as
like ID member ID the loan amount the
maximum loan amount that people can get
for a personal loan for Lending Club is
$40,000 so the range is from like five
hundred dollars to forty thousand
dollars you can request the amount right
but how much actually do you get uh do
they lend out so it has information
about that it has information about what
the status of the loan is whether the
loan is current whether they defaulted
on the loan it has the for instance the
zip code some parts of the zip code
additionally they have information about
what's the reason so some of them you'll
find some of our trying to pay for they
have credit cards that they're trying to
pay off other people are trying to maybe
pay for a wedding so or maybe pay for
college so this is a very interesting
very diverse data set I recommend that
you check out Kaggle and you can play
around with the data set so for this
we're going to import the loan so I
provide it to two
so the first file you're gonna see is
the the actual loan data set this is
about close to two gigs of data and then
the browse notes it's just a dictionary
of the of the features because some of
them are they're very cryptic some of
the stuff I had to look up if you like
what does this mean so if you have
questions you can we actually going to
bring it up so that way you can see okay
this is uh this is what the data set
looks like and if I don't know what the
feature means I can I can click on it so
you can select it there so can you
please run that we're gonna read it so I
guess the highlight here is she's really
the DTF Reid it's very simple you could
read up you you could input up right as
you see an URL and you can also do it
from directly from your local machine
let me show you
I also have it installed Python data
table in my machine so you can also see
the differences in terms of how fast it
is when you're doing it locally okay so
let me see okay so now that we have the
so notice that I we entered a time so
that way you can actually see how long
it takes from what uh my experience
running this uh this notebook you could
it took about maybe like 30 seconds with
data table for this particular notebook
but if you do it locally it took about
five seconds to do it
to upload 2.6 million rows or how many
of you are done already uploading the
data set how long did it take for most
of you 30 seconds okay so now try it
with pandas so run that and check to see
how long that takes you
so that would should take you about like
50 seconds or so okay so I ran it to
locally and took about eighteen point
four seconds we'll see how long it takes
for pandas so we're still still running
right so this is one of the advantages
at least that I found was it was awesome
that it takes less time to to upload
just to import the file so I know you
you'll get something a comment there
yeah 59 seconds so we already see there
are some benefits right to the data
table just on the on the using the DT
data frame F read file so that's how you
import a data set so where there is
everyone there everyone checked already
so we now what we have to the reason
that I wanted to so now we just imported
the data set and I just wanted to
highlight right the time differences
between them the two so as we're going
through this lab I'm gonna I'm we're
gonna be doing that we're going to be
running some simple commands but I just
want to show you the difference we want
to highlight the difference in terms of
performance because this is a library
that it's where we were highlighting
performance as Pasha said we're not
trying to replace pandas they we were
gonna show that you can actually work
well together right there are things
that you can do in pandas that you can
convert to data table and vice versa
okay so looking at the add the loan data
frame right so we want to look at the
well what is the data if you haven't
seen the the the data frame well if you
haven't seen the the notebook or the
data itself how does it look like so the
way that you could do that is using the
I'm sorry now what it looks like but
just the size of it you can use the
command here I
comment it out but if you take a print
detail loan and you paste it and you run
it you should be able to see the shape
of the of the data set so again the
count the the command should be comment
in the comment section itself so you can
you could find out the shape of the data
set run it right you could do the same
again for the figuring out the types you
can copy and just paste it and see okay
so those are again very simple commands
that you could use to kind of understand
a little bit more of the the data set
okay so I'm going to try to run this
quickly because I know we also have I
want to make sure we have a room time
for questions so if you want to look at
the at the you want to look at the other
data set right with data table all you
got to do is enter the name of the data
frame so when we when we imported the
data set we call it DT loan for data
table loan if you want to see it all you
got to do is enter DT loan the name of
the data frame and you get the first ten
rows followed by the last five so we did
say well about two sorry that was in two
point six it was 2.2 million but this is
what it looks like and we even Pasha and
the team actually made it so that it's
like celebratory it's anna has the
holiday it has a holiday theme so I
thought it was really awesome thank you
Pasha that was really cool yeah so you
can see that it's very simple you don't
have to do you set the head command you
could just do DT name the the frame and
it shows up so what else can we do
you can do this is for the the section
where I was talking about the features
or if you wanted to understand what the
features were right what does it mean so
you can actually look at the the name of
the feature of the column and look at
the definition there so again it gives
you the first ten and the last but the
last five this is one hundred and forty
five features so it will not you can get
a better idea right and it's really
nicely laid out sorry where am i right
here okay so that's the other part so
let's do some of the data wrangling
Pacha talked about already some of the
commands and what what the format should
look like
so again um this is gonna be like very
high level I know most probably most of
you are like expert data scientists they
could do very complicated analytical or
just do different analysis right for the
data wrangling but we're not gonna do
that we're just kinda I just want to
show you what you can do if you're
planning on doing dinner wrangling so
that way you can compare right you can
see the performance so we're going to
delete the following columns and how do
we do that
so I have two notebooks running at the
same time I just want a sec so all you
got to do is entered following command
to your notebook and by the way there's
also a cheat sheet I don't know if they
you guys can pass it around we have it
up here that has also commands for like
how to delete so we're gonna pretty much
talk about some of the other commands
that there are that we're going to run
it we're gonna run it on the notebook
but you can also reference it the cheat
sheet in case that you're like running
behind because some of the commands are
not here they will be posted on the
official notebook once he gets published
but yeah so all you gotta do is the do
the delete we have a delete function and
you could do they take the name of the
frame and because we're doing those
columns those columns there are missing
values so the ID and member ID they have
the columns but they're empty also the
URL and the desk are missing values as
well so I we're just gonna delete them
so you run shift and I'll delete it for
you so just a heads up the labs that we
have an aquarium they only last two
hours so if you do want to check out the
labs they they they will expire after
two hours that you will not be able to
save any of your any of your data but it
is really nice to excuse for exploration
purposes it does give you a warning but
you have to go to the aquarium page but
you guys should be I think you should be
okay so we're here so I'm just gonna use
the one that I have on my local machine
but it should be the same commands so
we're gonna look at the newly trimmed
data frame and just again we just have
to enter a DT loan simple as that and
you can see that uh-oh
yes it did not delete that
you know how it is for when you're doing
it that everything works until you're
doing actually doing the demo so thank
you for bearing with me so as you can
see right I just wanted to see did it
actually do it yes it got rid of the ID
you got rid of the member ID okay so
then the next part is we're going to so
this section is you could do it and uh I
wanted to generate IDs right and you
could do it with what data table but I
just wanted to show you that you can do
it in pandas you can create a new data
frame and then you can bind it together
right you can you can take pandas a
newly created data frame compared to
data table and then bind it so the way
that you could do this is by doing the
using pandas right you can write the uh
the new data frame and to convert it all
you got to do is take DT D frame enter
the name of the newly created of the
pandas the pandas dataframe we're gonna
name a data table ID cuz that's the ID
that was generated and we're going to
bind it so again this is just a
highlight that you can go from pandas to
data table data table to pandas very
simple again if you have some questions
you can look at the cheat sheet it has
different ways to convert from one to
pandas to data frame to numpy so check
it out I recommend it
okay so again now we just want to look
at the we want to specifically look at
the that the new data table frame for ID
so we went ahead and created a panda's
data frame where we generated IDs or
really an index and then we converted
that to data table frame and now we're
just showing it any questions so far
oh I know it's very like where most of
you probably like super basic so now
we're going to bind it we're going to
bind the newly created data frame ID
with the data frame loan so remember
that in the original
data table loan frame we deleted the ID
but now we're gonna add it back on so we
run it and now we're gonna view it okay
so simple as that okay so this is the
part where it gets good so thank you for
bearing with that one now we're gonna do
some exploratory analysis we're gonna
look at the mean so for the mean we're
gonna calculate the mean using data
table okay so you should have the
command should be on the comment so it
should look something like this so it's
a percent time DT loan me can everyone
does everyone have that yes are you are
you there
we're gonna calculate the mean at this
point and this is where we're gonna
start comparing pandas and data frame a
bit more in terms of the performance so
this one took 2.3 seconds now we're
gonna run it with pandas and just to
note that the the mean loan for this
particular data set was a thousand five
hundred so again we're talking about
personal loans oh wait just kidding
you're not supposed to run the pandas
because it's it actually my Jupiter lab
kept crashing every time I try to
calculate the mean so don't run it run
it at your own risk
I'm sorry it has commented out for a
reason I think it says do not run right
on yours yes don't I so he was my bad
okay awesome
alright so but if you want to try it on
your own at a different time please do
so and you can see the differences so
now we just calculate the max right it's
very simple take the name with the data
frame that you created and then that max
for the function so the maximum we
already talked about at the beginning it
was $40,000 so and then we do the meet
the minimum
and one thing that Pasha mentioned was
that if you calculate the max yolk so
get them in so you get two for one
is that correct Pasha yes okay so then
if you're trying to calculate them in
then it's already that for you should be
super fast and again we're just running
this so you can see that it's the
different functionalities for per data
table so now you can calculate the mode
turns out it was ten thousand dollars
for the mode which is very consistent
again with the if you look at the data
table at the the data itself and you can
calculate the standard deviation alright
so let me rush to sorting the frame so
we're gonna sort the frame using an of
the data frame Python data table okay so
sort it I believe that your your should
be commented out so if you just
uncommented you can run it so it should
look something where you has a percent
time sorted loans and it took eighty
four point um microseconds and you can
again view it just so you can confirm
right that it was sorted so it's sorted
from the lowest amount which is five
hundred dollars and the highest which is
four thousand so we're confirming that
it actually did what it's supposed to do
what else we have okay so now let's do
that with pandas so again eighty four
point four microseconds
just take note six point three seconds
yes with pandas okay so now we're going
to jump into the group by operations so
for this one for group I we were gonna
we're gonna do here is we're going to
group the the types of of loans so loans
get graded differently right bite risk
so we have a tie
a B C and D so we're just gonna take the
sum right of the types of loans that
they have and for this particular
section of the code what we did is we
could run it once but it's so fast that
you're just gonna get zero seconds so
you're not going to really see the
difference between the two so we ran
this command a hundred times so that you
can see it how long it takes to run a
hundred times compared to panda's so if
you run it takes 3.3 seconds and if you
want to view it just to verify that it
was actually done you can view it too
and you can see the number of the loan
amounts right for grid a for B C D again
if you're you're not too familiar if you
want to learn more about what the grades
are what do they mean you can go to the
lending club site they have all the
definitions for that okay so now let's
do it with pandas let's see how long it
takes so again most of your your in your
cells you just uncomment them I left
them in there for you so that way just a
little bit easier
okay so we got 3.3 seconds and for
pandas we have at least for me eight
point seven four how has it been for you
guys because I know it might be take a
little longer on the Jupiter lab what
are the the times what are we getting
for for group I for data table three
okay with pandas no nine point six nine
point five okay all right so we see some
I know it's like seconds but they start
adding up at some point okay pull
filtering rows again we did the same
thing we're filtering rows we're running
this 100 times so that way we can see
how long it takes okay so you just run
um
it out I know for you guys it's gonna be
uncommented so for this particular
section we're filtering out the the
loans that are greater than the mean and
we found that the mean was a thousand
five hundred or so so we're asking to
filter about 2.6 million rows right oh
just kidding so I'm sorry if we're going
kind of fast I wish like we could
provide more of an explanation but kind
of short on time so nine seconds the
Python again this is just for me you
don't have to do it but I wanted to see
like oh they did actually do it right
yeah so it turns out here filtered out
the the loan and it's cool too because
that way you can see the idea right you
can associate which loan amount which
which are the loans what was the amount
of the loan and who was the person who
was the ID of the per was the person
that got this loan in case that you need
to reference it for something else okay
so now we're gonna filter with pandas it
took to set at 2.5 seconds what was the
timing for you for for you guys for
filtering with pandas or for data data
table 15 for pandas oh boy 15 seconds oh
okay well guess this time well at least
for me it yeah
yes panda this one we did a little
better so yeah we're not tracking P it's
just more there's benefits to both so
for the model development for this
section this is not necessarily data
table but it's more of you know we're
just taking the S King learn and we're
gonna run a quick linear regression
we're just trying to see what the
relationship is between the loan amount
and installment and enter an interest
rate right so if you run it
we can kind of deduct by logic right
that asked the loan amount increases
that then the interest rate decreases
right by this percent here and as the
installments increase then your interest
rate decreases right so that's what
we're in a sense what we can conclude
from this but again you could do more of
a bond model development this is just
like a very simple model development if
you want to learn more about
specifically about this linear
regression there is a great tutorial but
SRK he is one of our Iago grandmasters
at h2o he build this a great tutorial
you can check it out and he provides
more information about this so getting
to the the one of the parts that stood
out to me is like ok now that I'm done I
want to save it so if you want to save
it just save with Python data frame and
we're saving a CSV it for me it took 2.9
seconds I don't know how long it's gonna
take for you guys how long did it take
for you can anyone send you one there
yet 1.3 seconds ok now try it with
pandas so one of the things that I did
see for in when I was running it in the
Jupiter lab for aquarium is that it
actually never gave me a time but what
you can do is that you can go go back to
the Jupiter lab the initial page where
we saw the different where we went to
upload the lab and you can see the two
data sets and you can see the size and
for the you can see that for data table
we actually uploaded the the data set
right away
and for pandas it does it in chunks so
it takes much longer so as you can see I
already have it's it's starting to it's
still working on it
so I hope
that you can see right that they are
great advantages to using data table
pandas works well as well there's
different things that you can do with
both we hope to see we hope that you can
see how easy it is to use I know that
for some of you who are not familiar
with our maybe the syntax may be may be
there might be a learning curve but I
definitely see that there there's
advantages for any if you we do have
great documentation and we're also
working on building more tutorials there
are more extensive and more complex so
for those of you who do want to learn
more about data table you have you
wouldn't be able to have an environment
as well as kind of more tutorials to
help you guide yourself with so what's
the next this is just like version one
of the tutorial we're hoping for the
next session section we can have next
version of tutorial we can have create a
section where we can create and update
columns we could do more joins column
selections functions for multiple
columns and then another part too is
that we do have a driverless AI which
Pasha mentioned the whole reason that
this library was created was because of
driverless AI right and so driverless
say I suppose it's really fast and so
you can actually take do all your data
wrangling with or with data table slash
pandas and then create a J file and
uploaded to driverless AI where you can
create develop model and you can
actually have machine learning
interpretation of your models so we're
we're gonna be working on a tutorial for
that where we can take you from creating
a J file to the Python client to h2o
driverless AI so hopefully they'll be
coming around January we are hoping to
post this tutorial on the github page I
mean under there's a landing page that
we have this is our what our tutorials
page looks like we have tutorials for
driverless tutorials for h2o
which is an open-source product and then
we'll be adding data table as well here
so please if you're interested if you're
curious the notebook that I will be
providing will have more information and
well it would be like a walkthrough so
you'll have it's not gonna be like today
we're just you're trying to run as much
as you can quickly you'll have you can
run it at your own pace so it looks like
Cupid are still working on downloading
the data set so oh nevermind this is
trying to run code when it's supposed to
be marked down all right
okay so as I mentioned data science is a
journey so I know most of you are self
learners go and check out our tutorials
we also have great documentation for
both data table and for the hto products
if you're interested
h2o dye provides the h2o aquarium which
you're welcome to use we have labs for
all our products and we're going to be
incorporating data table as well too so
again if you just want to get started
with with data table you can go to the
data table repo we they have great
documentation as you saw it's as simple
as doing a pip install and you can all
you'll get the latest and greatest of Pi
data table because we have very like we
have hard-working makers who are
constantly striving to make a grade
library so if you have any questions if
you're actually working on data table
you're using data table you have
questions you can go to stack overflow
and you can go and use the tags data
table Python and you can search for
questions that already been posted you
can also go to the if you actually like
want to contribute to the to the report
you want to report an issue you can go
to the github repo and create a new
issue if you would like to contribute to
the data table project you can
contribute by the improving
documentation report bugs request
features have you know if you have API
suggestions if you want to test itself
like you can do that how you can
contribute first of all if you want to
contribute to the project one of the
recommendations that Pasha I mentioned
is uh is that first check if there's an
issue first check that it's there all
right or that if somebody's once it's
contributing to you don't want to be
working on the same project or the same
thing if somebody else may be already
working on it so you want to make sure
that check that it that it already
exists right if your contribution is
something's already there that they're
not you're not doing double the work if
it doesn't create a new issue and then
Pasha right Pasha you will get back to
them to be able to
provide guidance because it is a very
large project and it's not so much for
it to tell you like what you need to do
is more to say hey if you're looking if
you want to work on this this is where
you can go to search and this is the
resources available to you so you get a
better a better understanding of what
the repo looks like and how to make it
easier for you to contribute because it
could be a little scary right we don't
know we don't want to discourage you
from not participating because it could
be a little confusing and then after you
get you do that you just do a pull
request so yeah so thank you again you
guys have any questions and answers or
questions and hopefully we have some
answers for you any any questions we do
have again - we have two of the makers
for this particular library here today
so please feel free to ask technical
questions now at this point questions ok
the microphones gonna please wait for
the microphone think thanks very much
for walking through this is very very
enlightening I'm ramsey from a trail
laboratories i just curious um could you
explain a little more about how the
virtual column thing works i'm assuming
that's why a lot of the processing was
faster is is that is that correct and
yes so a virtual column is basically a
column that knows how to compute
everywhere each and every of its
elements so usually it's a column that
stores a pointer to something to some
parent data and function to compute the
results on the data so usually you will
end up with a kind of da g and the
direct a cyclic a cyclic graph of
computations so you start with some
initial data set then you apply
different transformations to multiple
columns and say they interact with each
other and and you held up these columns
that depend on multiple levels of
multiple columns in the original data
set but still it's just a complicated
nested function of the original data so
and
basic observation is that to read and
write into memory is a more expensive
computation is more time-consuming than
computing so usually if you can read and
write less and compute more that's gonna
be beneficial for your performance which
is why we believe that it's it's good to
have these computer computer on the fly
call columns even if you end up maybe
performing some of the calculations
multiple times it's still it still will
cost you less time in the end and then
if you saved all those intermediate
results into into the memory and then
read that from that memory again so
which is how standards approach let's
say in pandas or not by the US a very
very cool library just curious what was
the thought process in creating a lot
the array extension types yourself
instead of maybe using something like
what high arrow offers or PI arrow for
performance and those know native arrays
so as I mentioned we started over two
years ago and at that point arrow was in
much younger stage and it was and is
right now it only barely started and
maybe if he started today's the process
view maybe we could have used the arrow
as a back-end and actually we talked a
little bit with our get help on how
better to integrate the projects we have
an issue for that and it was a little
bit complicated because we initially we
chose a different memory layout and
chosen in arrow because we started we
came from our data table but in the
recent year we made huge strides towards
virtualizing that data storage so now
it's
it's much easier to do the transit
transition toward error memory storage
so we are considering of having that
back-end as one of the possibilities
built-in mounted so that you could use
them and they could use us more easy
yeah hi any plans you know to to move
into distributed computing for example
to add support you know so we don't have
immediate plans or distributed computing
because you have to ask for that and so
task is a platform that takes pandas and
distributes it and it might as well just
take data table and also distributed it
using the same platform so currently we
will not we do not have plans to
distribute that but it's possible that
our calculation will change in the
future you decide that this is this is a
place to go but initiative will already
have a h2 library that that is
distributed data frame so I kind of want
to have something different so
all right thank you for everybody know I
know it's almost time to finish so I
just want to make sure personally -
thank you we're taking for being patient
whisky I know this was a long tutorial
well supposed to be a longer tutorial
but it's I know when you're running a
tutorial on a notebook trying to follow
set up the environment and running the
notebook itself it could be rough so
thank you and I would like to do a
special thank you to the makers
Pacha know let's see as well as RK Joe
and Joe Pinellas and Rafael cause they
were also contributed to to the
presentation and the tutorial so thank
you all again we will have a sprint
session right the two makers will be
there and they will be answering any
technical questions correct for the data
table so if you are kind of still
thinking about questions and you want to
maybe later on ask them like one on one
you can go ahead and ask them later so
thank you again for for sitting here
with us and again we'll be posting the
tutorial the notebook itself on the
website on our tutorials website so
please feel free to check it out in a
few weeks and if you have any feedback
please feel free to provide any feedback
as well
all right thank you
[Applause]